décédé en fait il y a une femme
magnifique derrière ah non franchement
et je pense que c'est ça qui fait qui
met non mais en fait le contraste vous
êtes magnifique
au paradis
sur la tête de ma mère quand tu vois le
paradis il y a une meuf comme ça qui
t'attend sur la tête des chats non mais
c'est un truc de fou vous êtes
magnifique c'est votre fille
quand on voit la mer on voit la fille
bah ouais bah tu vois Castaldi il a vu
que les mères
[Musique]
un truc de fou vous êtes magnifique
bon j'avais pas un micro on a toujours
des micros vous voulez pas vous appeler
demain pour parler
en train de discuter toi alors ça va ça
va toi tu te souviens quoi toi
[Rires]
c'est sympa merci comment vous appelez
Muriel mais vous êtes magnifique non et
franchement ah si franchement
[Rires]
célibataire non non enfin ma
connaissance non
tu as la tête du gars qui galère à
récupérer sa meuf la nuit non mais sans
déconner tu vois qu'il dort pas qui
galère à récupérer sa meuf bah ça oui
voilà oui voilà bonne santé
Muriel vous êtes magnifique vraiment
c'est très beau non c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
sortez tout le public sortez sortez j'en
ai rien à [ __ ] sortez
sortez sortez sortez sortez sortez
tous vous voyez pas que je suis Rabat il
sortait mettez vous là-bas mettez-vous
là-bas sortez sortez complètement sortez
faites les sortir et sortir les gens
allez-y allez-y merci les chéris merci
d'être venu merci d'être venu vous êtes
des amours merci les amours sortez
sortez sortez il y a une alerte amour
une alerte le sentiment merci de sortir
merci sortez sortez à demain sortez vite
dépêchez-vous l'amour n'attend pas
dépêchez-vous
dépêchez-vous merci merci sortez tous
sortez sortez sortez bah oui toi aussi
tu veux rester seul avec ma meuf pas
possible non mais ils discute lui en
plus pourquoi il me dit non mais oh
merci les chéris sortez tous là-bas
là-bas
sortez sortez les mecs la sécurité
occupez vous de ça faites-moi sortir
tout le monde je vais être seul avec ma
meuf merci
sortez sortez maniez-vous le cul
bordel ils sont sortis les chroniqueurs
sur terre
sortez sortez tout le monde genre tout
le monde sort on va voir personne merci
les chiens allez-y allez boire un café
c'est pour moi prenez ce que vous voulez
allez-y prenez un café c'est pour moi
prenez ce que vous voulez
excusez-moi
allez-y les chéris merci les chéris
merci vous pouvez y aller merci allez-y
barrez-vous les images
merci les chéris merci merci d'être déjà
à vous merci de partir merci de partir
au plus vite partez partis partez restez
pas là
c'est que des cochonneries vous n'avez
rien à voir
allez-y merci je vais aller vérifier
juste c'est les chroniqueurs se sont
mariés merci merci les chroniqueurs
sont encore là
et chroniqueurs oui oui
tu peux mettre à côté
[Musique]
tu as pas des devoirs à faire toi
ma chérie
j'aime pas quand il y a beaucoup de
monde ça m'oppresse
tu fais quoi dans la vie
plus rien tu faisais quoi je m'occupe de
ma fille
merci ça va tu faisais quoi avant
[Musique]
j'ai envie de t'inviter à danser un slow
avec plaisir
[Musique]
les mec on dirait un film érotique là
[Applaudissements]
je t'aime beaucoup merci ma chérie moi
aussi
[Musique]
mais tu es pas tu passes
de pécho là
mais c'est quoi ces voyeurs là mais vous
voulez quoi
on va voir ce qui se passe
[Musique]
ne t'occupe pas de ça Muriel